[Music]
we're gonna start the show the way I
started with the people that I love that
are instant family which you are
by giving you a present oh my God and
you're gonna open it and you guys are
not going to complain about the freaking
tissue paper noise
hold on this is for
first I want you to open the one
that's for you and then I went for your
sister that's for you oh my God okay
thank you don't don't thank me till
you've opened it I mean it could just be
deodorant because I want to tell you
something it could be mouthwash
you know those gifts where people give
it to you and you're like do I stink
this is a cologne that I you might hate
it if your girlfriend hates it you throw
it in the trash
but this is Santa Maria remember we
talked about
Europe I I'm obsessed with like I smell
everything
a rat because everything's about to rap
because you work in Hollywood
does that smell good it's like a tobacco
smell
so so good we bonded instantly uh not
just because we were amazing we were
trapped in a hotel together and he had
no choice but to talk to me but I am
such a smells person and you immediately
were like what's that smell and I was
like oh my God I I this is so dorky when
I do a character I pick a perfume yeah
yeah yeah me too it's so dorky Penelope
Cruz said it once in an interview and I
went oh yeah and for the character I did
in your movie I was like she's this like
brassy makes too much money she would
wear something overpriced but also tacky
like just because you have money does
not mean you have class just because you
have money does not mean you have taste
so I was like yeah I want to find an
expensive perfume that of course I'm not
gonna pay for I'm gonna DM the brand and
get it for free
um and
I I was wearing it just to kind of like
experiment and it's the first thing you
said and I was like we talked about
perfume for like an hour yeah I remember
I'm like there's no one I can talk about
perfume with so I grew up in a
department store my mom worked at
Bloomingdale's and I worked as a perfume
girl at the counter so anyway
this smells amazing
is it good yeah because also don't you
think perfumes smell different on
different people yes and on different uh
yeah yeah yeah
is it and I love no no because I love
how it's kind of like has like this like
tobacco but like it's not for every day
but it might just be like this this
smells really good I'm not I'm not
saying you guys he's one of the best
actors I've ever worked with so I kind
of believe what he's saying but take it
with a grain of salt no it I I swear to
God by the way I believe you it smells
amazing it's good right and also Santa
Maria Naval like I love those bottle
it's from Firenze Italy which is Firenze
Florence sorry I'm trying I'm trash I'm
white trash and I know you've seen me
act but I can't even act like I'm not
off camera like I fight renze by the way
I still say Hermes is it Hermes is it
Hermes I tweeted out hey Hermes you need
to make a commercial clarifying how to
pronounce because there's a lot of
influencers in La arguing at parties
about this brand so clarify for the
idiots that have new money and don't
know
oh and I bought you a little something
too a big something where is it have I
drank it already
where I put it okay where is it do you
it's under me oh sorry okay sorry I'm
just it's inside me I
he brought me his tequila I'm like where
is it oh excuse me hold on
there it is smells great so this is your
tequila yeah
it's not out in the U.S yet because we
just wanted a launch in Mexico first
contraband
just for you you know what else isn't
out in the US yet women's rights so it's
fine it we get things later than
everyone else we just it takes us a
while this is
did you carry it on the plane or check
it I had the guys send me bottles here
for friends and no Fentanyl
this isn't like the Mexican cocaine I've
been using recently right
just kidding I've never done cocaine
which is weird should we do it right now
for the first time
so is that what this says here we also
have salt we're gonna make I'm gonna
have for the first time then we're gonna
talk about Diego's fucking ridiculously
impressive World takeover as what I
believe is going to be the biggest movie
star in the world for sure
um and we're gonna get to it all but
podcasts are casual they're fun they're
easy people are gonna see you on talk
shows answering all these questions on
this show you're gonna hang out yeah and
we're gonna freaking drink and have a
good time I love it you're off the clock
this is gonna be fun except you're gonna
have to call the police when I when you
see what kind of person I turn into when
I drink tequila
well this is something so I've I've been
drinking tequila yeah you run Point okay
what are the okay here do you normally
drink on the rocks or neat I'm a
comedian comedians put roofies in drinks
and we just decide that's ice but these
are these are the ice cold rocks so so
that the ice will melt your drink and
dilute it yeah okay so so this is not a
Mezcal the difference between Mezcal and
this is one is smokier right so the
difference so
I'll tell you here okay I'll just have
to try it
um the difference between Mezcal and
tequila is the following tequila is made
out of Blue Agave it's only made out of
Blue Agave one type of agave and it has
the nomination of origin in Tequila
Jalisco Jalisco is a state the capital
of that state is Guadalajara yes okay
yes and tequila is
a re like a like a region or like a town
in Jalisco so it has denomination of
origin like champagne can I ask you do
is that the place that like Blue Agave
was indigenous to that because I'm sure
other places could grow but is it like
that it's a good question
did you hear that good question see I
should have a podcast I deserve this I
asked a good question
I don't know how about this you guys
Google it
I'm definitely gonna find out uh but I'm
a tequila lover I've been drinking
tequila my whole life there's different
categories how young did you start I
mean I first tried to heal with my dad
when I was like 12. I you're like I was
breastfed tequila my mom started me
early
so I want to not be a trash American
asshole I look you in the eyes yeah okay
not at seven years of bad sex
seven more
by the way is there such thing as good
sex wait hold on
we'll Circle back to that but so I don't
drink this off someone's tits I don't
put salt on it don't put salt on it you
just sip it
just have a sip like you just like like
little kisses okay before you try just
let me tell you really little kisses you
these thank you
exactly you have to with Americans with
drinking like in a way that we
appreciate it because I think a lot of
times Americans we drink to get it over
with
yes small sips looking at the eye that's
too much can I look at her can I look at
anyone else
we're just like uh okay small sips yeah
okay every tequila I've ever drank Burns
Burns of course
not this one and by the way you're like
and then you're like all right I guess
I'm just gonna do that and I think that
tequila makers in America they like
watching a girl just gag they're like
yeah they're like I'm like this is this
is supposed to be an enjoyable
experience this is news to me it also
coats your mouth
like a
it's very sexual
that was so like have you felt it on
your mouth
how much am I allowed to have as much as
you want what's okay and tell me why you
named it this because I'm fascinated by
that so we called it the frente which
means
straightforward like just
straightforward this is a Blanco tequila
there's different categories you have
silver or Blanco you have Reposado you
have Anejo okay
and you have cristalino which is an aged
silver the only category where you
cannot put any additives is a Blanco
tequila now different to wine or whiskey
right people think oh
the older the better not with tequila
true tequila with women exactly exactly
uh
by the way that said my tits are only
two years old so
you know old brain good you know we
gotta sometimes tune up other parts
I've I've I've always loved older women
that like always okay um smart that's by
the way the best guys do and you know
what's crazy I always thought like when
I by the way it's so weird that when
your body is the tightest you're the
dumbest it's so unfortunate I'm like I
was the craziest when I was so like
young but now and then I thought I was
like oh my god when I get older I'm just
gonna be put out to pasture
like it you know that the number one
porn uh search is MILF no way men when
no one's looking or like I just want to
see a mature woman with some cellulite
like
who might have because dark nipple after
you give birth your nipples are darker
because the baby has to find it you know
what I mean yeah like and a MILF knows
how to fuck
a lot of these young porn girls are like
I was like is she okay whereas melts are
like let's fucking move I got 10 minutes
we're in we're out
so anyway I appreciate that because I
think there's a myth that men like
younger women I don't think that's true
it's a myth no I mean I I always dated
older until my current yeah yeah like
yeah I always dated older men because I
just we needed someone to drive me to
school
now that I have my own car I only get
younger
who's older now I'm like your knee your
knee doesn't work you're slowing me down
anyway I'm sorry
sorry it's just I can't I can't deal
with an ex-wife who's yelling at me like
I just I'm like I need a little bit
younger just for now
not emotionally younger but like because
younger younger guys like you know the
older men at least in America it's not
their fault but like they didn't see
Beyonce they didn't see Oprah they
didn't see a black president like now
these younger guys they have different
data on women they didn't watch a bunch
of movies where women were just a sex
object you know like they're you're make
you just made a movie where the girl was
fucking 10 dimensional
and and guys are going to see that I'm
sorry to be serious but this like it
bring it truly I'm not even joking like
it brought me to tears to even be a part
of this movie even though I'm a monster
at it which
you're amazing
the fact that you guys left that stuff
in is like psycho the fact that you were
boxing with Giovanni Porter
that literally we're about to shoot the
scene where I'm boxing being like an
asshole
and they're like you know let's just
have like him and I had he's amazing
he's hilarious we were like um and Jonah
the director who is like amazing he's
gonna be the biggest he's who fucking
Woody Allen thinks he is
sorry Woody Allen's movies are not that
they're not funny I said it they're not
that good
I said it
and he goes to Madrid and fucking to
make it seem better than it is it only
the only reason we're watching it is
because you shot it in Spain and you
know that
um and so uh uh apologize me nuts
Charlotte Johansson and um uh uh
Penelope how dare you
waste their time I know how much they
got paid
so
we're shooting and like it felt like a
family it was it was like sometimes when
two good things are too good to be true
they seem they are and when I worked on
your movie I went this is too good to be
true
and it's true like no shoes gonna drop
and that was very weird for me like I
went into the bathroom after we shot and
I went
they can't use any of that like it was
too fun I just had fun in a scene
there's no way they're going to use it
the Network's going to say no I failed
them I went too far and then I watched
the movie and I'm like
you left in the Shirley Temple thing
like that's calling out Hollywood I and
then I was like because I got I went
into the bathroom and I was like I can't
believe I did that now they can't use it
they're gonna get into post and they're
gonna be like Whitney didn't give us any
usable takes
I thought you were gonna get into post
and go the one day I wasn't on set this
fucking bitch goes the hard part was
choosing what yeah because everything
was so fucking funny we they let me go
we went for 30 minutes I was like you
guys this is gonna be 10 seconds and I
got like what do I it was embarrassment
of riches we were having so much fun but
so then the writer and I were having
everyone's having dinner that never
happens on a movie the the the producers
don't talk to that it's not one big
happy family usually because I I came
down to Mexico and you guys have been
shooting a couple weeks I was like I'm
gonna be what you know when you walk
onto set after people have been there
two weeks yeah people are already
fighting two people have already had
affairs and broken up people are you're
walking into a nightmare and everyone's
like can you get me the thing and you're
just like I'm only here for a couple
days just just don't let this affect you
and so the writer they're like how about
he's the personal trainer in it the
person I'm gonna be a dick to that I'm
punching at and I'm like I kind of want
to be in the sequel you guys so can I
not punch the writer
like what if I hurt I was literally like
being an asshole I'm in the scene so I
was like and then afterwards like sorry
I love you and I love the script and I'm
sorry and then
I do want to finish this conversation
about the tequila because then I want to
tell you a story about your sister who
was a producer on the movie who is
my boss
[Laughter]
who's also weirdly terrifying because
you don't want to disappoint her
everyone was like
just on their best behavior because you
guys were leading by example with these
huge hearts and I went wait a second
there's a way to make movies with all
this pressure and all this stress and
all this deadlines we have to meet
and no one's UPS no one it doesn't have
to be done yes and be nice you know who
does It in America the only person is
Adam Sandler
he he goes we're going to Hawaii bring
your family we're working eight to six
we all have dinner together I hire the
same people every time every movie makes
90 million dollars
people love it and if you feel it on the
screen that they're having fun and
really love each other yeah
this show is sponsored by betterhelp now
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you feel overwhelmed or
like you're not showing up at it the way
that you want to
you know what better help I like that
you wrote that for me to read but I'm
gonna be honest things are a little
Bleaker for me I wish my biggest problem
was being overwhelmed
um my biggest problem is we can't find
my Mom's ashes I'm not fighting
overwhelm I'm not overwhelmed enough
about my mom's death I'm still laughing
about it which means I need to cry soon
what I actually like is you can switch
and have different people because truly
sometimes I'm like I kind of want to
talk to a guy about this then I kind of
want to talk to a woman about you know
it's just like that's my own stuff like
I don't need these are just all better
health counselors on all these screens
I'll just out of all these computers
just had like better help counselors
just well hold on you hold on hold on uh
uh Dr Dr Mason give me one second I just
I have another better help counselor on
I just want to run it by him don't go
anywhere you go okay so you I like to
pit them against each other
I'd be like someone had used that okay
well he just said this so he just said
you don't know what you're talking about
if you want to live a more empowered
life therapy can get you there that's
basically what I was just saying was I
not saying this exact thing visit
betterhelp.com Whitton today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
hellp.com Whitney
want to hear more about stop I can't
stop letting me talk I can't get this
down my gullet if I talk
to tell me to shut up no
no uh
I worked on this for two years
it's a silver tequila why silver like
two tequila lovers always drink silver
because it's the only one with no
additives the reposado and the Anejo
they all put vanilla next time you try
Don Julio 70 or literally smell it
because they want it to taste like a
stripper
stop making tequila for kids
don't put don't put flavors in it it's
remember they put flavored Vapes and
everyone's like this is obviously just
for children you know what I mean and
then you you're robbed of the building a
relationship with how tequila is
supposed to taste so I've always been
obsessed with trying to find the
smoothest silver
why silver because there's no additives
there's no fucking vanilla and by the
way additive sorry or what give you
headaches the next day yeah hangover do
you know what I mean clean the only
thing I can drink that doesn't give me a
like hangover and also bad sleep
so you sometimes you have a couple
drinks it's sugar bullshit and then you
get the worst sleep of your life and
you're not getting real the pure what
you drink is the better your sleep the
better your day the next day what's the
point of relaxing with a great drink if
the next two days your body is brain or
trashed yeah yeah
and I partnered up with this amazing
company let's go this is yeah you get it
was a pretty culture okay where I come
from you try to get girls drunk okay
what's what's this shit where you're do
you see he gave me this much God stingy
stingy
I found these amazing guys uh uh who run
a company called casalumbre and they uh
they make Mezcal montelobos they they
didn't tequila Milagro back in the day
they've been doing this which means
miracle miracle yeah
yeah and you know they're uh they're
Jewish they're they're Mexican they're
super smart they have such a great
operation uh and we partnered up
together and they said Diego
There's an opportunity here to do a
Blanco tequila which is just super
smooth and it's not 100 bucks a bottle
you know very similar to what I hate
that shit I hate that shit when
something is like yeah of course it's
delicious but it's only for five rich
people it's just like I hate that
prohibitively I don't like that only
rich people can afford to relax and
enjoy nice things yeah I mean and look
how big the bottle is sometimes they'll
sell you something for 200 and it's this
big you're like
look at what Tito's vodka did you know
Tito's vodka just
revolutionized killed it I know people
that drink it all day in a red cup I
mean yeah at work and you have you had
Gray Goose before and Belvedere and then
Tito said there's no status and
overpaying
that's what that's what Tito's vodka
like like that was their like that was
when I see someone with like a
prohibitly expensive like when you're
drinking wine it was like here's the
shout out to the pop that's George
you're like the Petrus this isn't fun
because we're all just like like
stressed out that we're gonna spill like
don't open it you're causing stress
because this is so expensive this is
supposed to be relaxing and fun I look
at this bottle and I go you're sharing
this with your friends and family yeah
it's
it's a family you know it's
a bottle you know and we really yeah
yeah
yeah but we wanted to launch in Mexico
first
so yeah we started working on this like
two two years ago and I was like guys
I'm only gonna do a tequila if I can say
it's the best tequila I've ever had and
let me say something about because right
now there's a little bit of an epidemic
I think in Hollywood and and I don't
blame them like go do what you have to
do for your backup plan like any actor
who's like or actress who's like I'm 45
I'm famous I'm gonna put my name on an
alcohol so that I can make money in my
sleep and not have to like go to you
know Albuquerque for eight months out of
the year can you imagine dude we worked
so hard to to get these huge
opportunities they finally come your way
and they're like hey Whitney
it happened
offered to be starting a show with your
favorite director writer I'm like oh my
God so great where is it you you now
live in Albuquerque nine months out of
the year I'm like yeah
no thanks
I love you Albuquerque but like I got a
horsey I got dogs I can't just live in
Albuquerque in like an Airbnb you know
like a camping you know so so a lot of
actors now they have it they have a wine
they have a you know a gin and you're
like I'm not mad at you for doing this
this has always happened in Hollywood
put your name on a Furniture line of
this but they don't have time to be
involved their perfumes like the fact
that you aren't just that's not what
this is you know what I mean and that
means so much and we worked so hard and
I was I was tough I was like listen I'll
do I I would I would do blind tastings I
did I don't know how many blind tastings
because I had my favorite Silver Tequila
that I always drank and I was like until
I don't like this more than what I drink
it's not done I just learned something
about you uh that's fascinating and
sorry I feel like this podcast we have
fun but then sometimes I go like wait
here's the lesson I'm learning because I
think everyone that listens to podcast
for the most part they want to laugh but
they also kind of want to learn I have a
theory that most people don't want to
stay dumb or ignorant and if they do
that's fine but they're not going to
come here you know but
I struggle in what I do as a leader and
making art or stuff with the vocabulary
to explain so different words mean
different things to different people so
I have a June shine Brand This is my um
hard kombucha Rave and when we did
tastings I had a hard time using words
that everyone that it translates so you
go it's just too um
like
bitey you know and everyone's like no
like well you know how like it kicks at
the end but then it's like in the
beginning and they're like no like how
did you learn because also with the
movie it's very clear that you the
director Monica the set designers
costume you were able to talk to people
with language that maybe it's different
in you know in America because we're not
connected to our feelings so maybe you
were able to give feedback in a way that
they like real and you have the
vocabulary to understand what are the
words you use in a blind tasting to go
I want this to be more blank more less
bling so this very famous uh Mexican
singer who passed Juan Gabriel who has
the second largest music catalog in the
world after the Beatles I mean he was
like a mentor and we did some songs
together and stuff and we were writing a
song and I was like 15 years old and I
was trying to make you know I was
writing it about this girl and I was
like but I feel that it's like the moon
and like the stars
The Beatles are The Beatles Because what
you're feeling they were able to just
say it and I Want to Hold Your Hand yep
so The Virtue is in making something
that you feel it's so complicated
simplifying for everyone for everyone to
understand it is harder to be simple 100
it's the truly intelligent like
brilliant people can distill a very
complex emotional into something that
everyone understands
yeah that's what we do as comedians we
have to go I want to convey this notion
but when I say it this way no one laughs
it makes sense to me
and when I say it this way half the
people laugh still not there now I gotta
pick a different word
now Applause break the comedians are so
smart come on
some of us
so so how so that's fascinating to me
like and was that something as soon as
he said it you got it was like oh yeah
it's stuck
in my life and in my work and everything
do you want to know something that like
these moments in your life where you
because to me I look at your career I
look at you and your sister and your mom
and are building and I go
that guy got so much wisdom so young
most people I'm like like I'm fascinated
what's the best advice you got like like
one of the best piece of advice I got
from a teacher a lot of teachers
sucked that we had and that's not their
fault they're underpaid yeah they're
like these kids are monsters well I
invest in them like you know he's he
obviously saw the potential knew how
hard you were working how talented you
were but you know I I've always had
trouble kind of articulating I kind of
we call like neurodivergent now but
I didn't know how to ask for help I
would stay confused and try to solve it
on my own and I remember being in a
music class and uh I was horrible at
music I'm so dyslexic I just I couldn't
do it I just was like and the teacher
would talk to me and I wouldn't I
wouldn't understand what he meant I'm
really good at seeing someone do
something and then I can do it but if
someone tells me how to do it I'm like
like I'm just like because I get
distracted by like the zit on their face
and their teeth and I'm like why
wouldn't you floss that's weird like I
get distracted my OCD I'm like do you
think you're pulling that toupee off
like you think I don't see it like so I
get distracted but if someone just does
it in front of me I can do it but I was
trying to figure out how to play like a
recorder or some bullshit excuse me I'm
very busy I'm like the biggest star in
Mexico excuse me sorry the fact that my
phone is not on is off is wild
um and he said it's better to not
practice at all than to practice sloppy
practice makes perfect but it has
perfect practice makes perfect better to
not practice at all for a week
then practice shitty
every because you're gonna develop
and that changed my life
because I was like I'm just gonna study
it while I'm running well
just do it
intensely and well better to do for 10
minutes than shitty for four hours yeah
that's great advice it's like the kind
of thing we're like yeah duh but I just
needed someone to say it to me because I
think I don't know if this is the same
you know for you in America we're so
focused on working
hard and not smart and we don't
acknowledge how neurology works if
you're working hard but distracted your
brain is your the muscle memory is
you're going to just keep doing you're
gonna go on autopilot and do that so the
people that I know that
speak most languages play the most
instruments
they learned it in six months they just
focused on it yeah
yeah
I'm I'm terrible at multitasking
if I if I'm doing someone by the way
that just produced for a movie okay yeah
produce four movies starred in It
produced it but yeah that's why my
sister's amazing how about this I think
we're terrible at multitasking on things
that bore us
you know what I'm saying you know people
pathologize me a lot and they're like
you have ADD you have this and I'm like
no I'm just bored
I I can multitask when it's stuff
Haley's like uh Haley's like ah
uh do you want to chime in here Haley
once I act once you Wrangle me
you know we have three shows in
post-production right now and it's just
like I'm literally like you know but I
think that we're good at things that we
love Yeah kids when they're bad in
school
they just they're bored I think you know
and it's like you have to learn math I
know it's boring but the teacher has to
find a way to make it interesting to a
10 year old you know when you have a
great teacher it's my thing is do the
chalk in color
don't make it white chalk boring boring
make math colorful okay you know so it's
like I think we just you know sometimes
don't want to admit something's just
kind of boring yeah
you know yeah I'm great at multitasking
when it comes I mean it's like I say I
say I'm bad at multitasking but then I
can date four guys at once it's like
it's you know it's like it's just an art
yeah
not not a very uh uh valuable one um but
this is
it's weird because
I think that everyone has this story
about alcohol or liquor whiskey makes me
angry you know gin makes me racist like
they'll be like uh you know on June I
just start hating Mexicans you're like
no you're racist like that's not the J
you know what I mean but I think so much
of
when
it's so much of that's about the
additives and the shit that's in these
half of these drinks that we drink are
poison and listen the tequila used to
always drink
had additives Don Julio 1970.
the guys that I was making this with Go
Diego just
smell this close your eyes
I go shit this smells like a vanilla ice
cream because yeah
it's vanilla we want to make a silver
tequila that's naturally smooth
so we found this incredible distillery
in atotonilco which is in the in the
tequila region which you have to come to
It's amazing And you know Yvonne who's
our tequila master I call him Dr Agave
because he's just
incredibly smart
um and it's made mezcals and so it just
he's incredible you know for two years
we're just like
okay we have our Distillery we're very
lucky because normally when you start
something you're sharing the kitchen
with 200 other brands so you can't
really uh whoa that's wild to think
about you know you're at the mercy of
what they're you can't try shit out you
know because you're sharing the kitchen
with 200 other tequila brands that are
starting
but we were very lucky because we had
our own just we have our own Distillery
so Yvonne was able to like really
work is Magic it was like Diego I want
to make this the way tequila was made
way back in the day because everyone
wants to rush he's like let me slow down
and do these as the Navy Seals say my
favorite saying slow is smooth and
smooth as fast yeah
hey y'all too busy to cook or just won't
do it because you're too much of a brat
like me well with Factor skip the trip
to the grocery store and Skip The
Chopping prepping cleaning up and crying
too factors fresh never frozen meals
already in just two minutes so all you
have to do is heat it up and enjoy it
they changed my life when my mom died
which I will stop bringing up very soon
Factor
supported me through my mom's death more
than any of my own friends it was like
they were all healthy and you just put
them like heated them up I put sometimes
I would just put them straight in the
microwave sometimes I would put them in
the oven I had to factor meals.com
whitney50 and use code 50 to get 50 off
your first box that's crazy that's code
Whitney 50. at first I was like do they
think I'm 50. it's 50 off it has nothing
to do with my face
Whitney 50 at factormeals.com Whitney to
get 50 off your first box love you do it
I feel like you and me and your sister
were like past life twins like we were
we were like triplets like in a past
life yeah we like literally we've hung
out twice this is us hanging out twice
by the way we're talking about truly
twice
and we like same brain sorry
and except he's way more talented but
anyway yeah and
um Yvonne was like you know I want to
bring a down nine okay what is that I
have it well it's a volcanic rock that's
used to press the Agave once it's cooked
in these
ovens made out of volcanic rock and he's
like telling me all these things we go
to the distiller he's like look you cut
the Agave the Blue Agave you put it in
these
uh ovens made out of volcanic rock you
put the agave in this and I'll show you
pictures this like big like round thing
and there's this rock made out of
volcanic rock that's pressing down as
t-a-h-o-n-a say it again
t-a-d-a-t-a-h-o-n-a I'm dyslexic so
we'll see what happens here what comes
out to hona Bar our mission is to
educate give reverence to complexity and
beauty is that right no let me here
I have it right here I'll show it to you
we can also put it in posts like
um shared albums while you say this I'm
going to say
so
this is fascinating
um
volcanic rocks I just said what are the
properties it's
they absorb and radiate heat very well
obviously it's a volcano but
it makes it so you can heat things
without like fire and smoke and taint it
so the same way this ice is a rock
that's cold it's going to keep it pure
but also it has oxygen and silicon most
abundant elements of volcanic rocks it
has other elements such as aluminum
calcium iron sodium here it is but but
Diego do you see that volcanic rock has
calcium iron and magnesium so it's also
full of
minerals minerals yeah yeah
and look so this is it and what's great
is back in the day this was pulled by a
donkey right
but in our Distillery it's all green so
you see all the
follow me like Agave this what that's
what we use to power The Distillery
so it's all green
this is these are the pineapples which
is what they're called it's the Agave
once they cut the leaves this is what
they cook
so look wow that is like a it's like
Narnia for distilleries it's so
beautiful and look at the feels so in
atotonilco
wow they have like this like uh like the
Earth is almost like red and this is how
you how the himador which is what that
man you know what what their job is to
to cut the leaves of the blue agave
wow
um this is you know can I tell you
something if this this is the only guy
you're gonna send me this photo I want
making my tequila this guy wow oh my God
look at that the the shirt he's wearing
the brand ah see can I tell you we have
to return
tasks like this to The Artisans like
we're now going oh hey my dad is in
Hollywood now I'm going to run a
Distillery like no no these are the
people that should be making stuff we
put in our bodies
you too
you guys look how happy you are it's
like I invite you to come down to the
disorder you're gonna you don't have to
invite me I'm already coming whether you
want me to or not this is one of my
partners okay uh single or no married
okay well so then
um these are the ovens so those
pineapples I'm half Jewish so I'm not
going in an oven that's
with that I need to really think it
through but okay I'll be there I'll just
so you put the the Agave is in there
they get the
do you before you cut them this is the
cook together which is like so sweet and
that's kind of like the aftertaste that
this has it's like it's super sweet so
is the juice there clear
yes wow and that's the juice that
vitiana that rock that I showed you
presses you guys if if people drink this
tequila will their hairline be this good
is that it just curious this is just
saying whatever he's doing do it wow and
it tastes so sweet
um let me ask you a question because I'm
curious about
the Agave is like I am a little bit you
know I just lost two parents I think
when you get older and you know you
start and you become a boss you start to
be more conscious of
I think a big problem we have in America
is that the people at the leaders at the
top are not
and I think it's intentional ignorance
conscious of their supply chain so I
don't want to be a bummer but we're just
finding out that the Cobalt and all
these phones are made by
children in Chicago
the people at the top should know that
you know so a lot of the stuff that I
buy I'm like is this humanely made where
was this sourced was was someone paid
four dollars to make this because
otherwise I don't want to participate
like to for you to be
this to be a supply chain that is so
pure it you feel it you feel it you know
in America
yeah that's all I really cared and and I
wanted to be able to tell my friends
like dude this is honestly the best
tequila I've ever tried that I've ever
had and it's smooth and it's there's no
additives and it's not 200 bucks a
bottle you know what it's not it's not
mean of most tequila I'm like ah okay we
had to do that and then we have to I
usually do you realize most tequila the
whole deal is you have to chase it with
a lemon because it's so hard to drink
yeah why have we not been like wait a
minute why did we
enter into the reality that drinks
should go
see ing that you should enjoy tequila
because America I guess the ones that
have been made so far have been made
by idiots drunks I don't know because
sometimes I'm like research aren't going
to Tequila that you forgot to
make sure it tastes did good to people
that haven't drank yet I don't know like
at least it's a tequila made by a
Mexican
there we go you know I mean I mean most
things in America are made by Mexicans
we just don't credit them but
um that's a different story for another
day uh we just don't pay them or
give them benefits or insurance but
we'll deal with that later but also the
reason I'm drinking a lot of this in
front of you is because I want to show
like
we've done episodes where we'll like
drink and just for fun get Whitney drunk
like I'm not getting dumb I'm not get
I'm I feel like warm and
more present so I think a lot of people
drink to check out yeah I don't want to
do that yeah no me neither I want to be
more present of course and more
um soft you know and I think a lot of
people are asked
I think a lot of people are in so much
pain that they kind of drink to go
forget
and but there's so many people that
don't want that I mean I we did an
episode of a show with the magician and
I don't like magic I it's it's morally
wrong I think it's the devil's work I
magicians I'm happy for you but don't
come near me
I I'm very I just don't pull that shit
around me it's not right you're because
people going hey I'm gonna lie to you
and we're like cool like it's weird and
there's no female magicians really which
because if a man is like lies to you
we're like magic if a woman does a card
trick people like see I told you women
lie they're crazy what'd I say like it's
like I you know I'm sorry about it
you're right yeah there's no female
magicians well there's one in Vegas now
named Jen Cramer she's new she's she's
huge now I talked about this once and
then someone reached out was like no
there is one now but if a man is on
stage and they like also why why is your
main
tricks sawing a woman in half ew
people like watch me saw a girl in a
like think of another trick why like ew
why did and then people like she saw it
in half Yay good can you also tape her
mouth shut while you're at it like it's
just so weird
like why this is a weird act and I'm a
comedian and I say some really wild shit
and I'm like and then they'll like lie
they put they put birds in their pocket
like stop it stop like you're this is
gross and they're just you know they're
weird you know they're weird and we all
know it like David Blaine's like I'm
gonna puke up a frog we're like here's
10 million dollars it's like
by the way call me um
something about David Blaine I'm gonna
say it I don't care you know you know
this happened and you know I have a
crush on you but
we were at a private thing
a friend of mine the singer Sia had
David Blaine at her uh birthday and it
was just a couple of us and we were
talking and he did kind of call me out
because I joke I made I made fun of him
on Twitter once I didn't mean to I just
was like stupid back in the day when we
were all tweet jokes those days are over
um and it was a joke about Chris Angel
that other one I don't know it was just
silly it was like flirting you know
comedians will make fun of you we just
we want to be your friend and we screw
up whatever
so the party's like hey remember when
you like made fun of me on that thing
and I was like
oh sorry I didn't I totally forgot
um and then we started talking he was
like is that the new iPhone and I was
like yeah and he like grabbed it I was
like I'm so sorry I'm sorry comedians we
just make jokes it's not I didn't think
you'd ever see it I'm sorry I don't
like in the car hour later phone rings
David Blaine
programmed into my phone
he calls me he had my phone for maybe 10
seconds 15 seconds
that's a trick I can get behind
that is Magic I like
and it was like how you know so that you
could have good game but don't don't
pull a bird out of your
you know lapel
um like here's a bunny I've had in my
pocket for two days like you know like
so anyway we're on the podcast I get a
margarita it's like a margarita from the
store
eight twelve dollars I'm sipping it
I black out
four hours later the footage I will send
it to you I'm like you're a witch
[Music]
I wear magic underwear I'm doing my
Fades what magical vaginal increase like
her uh Keyhole do you do what is wrong
why do you want me to be alone forever
that's what I saw you in half
motherfucker it was 48 proof alcohol
what
why is that even for sale
what why is that even 48 48 I I've never
blacked out drunk in my life I've never
I just was thought I was sipping in
Margarita like we're having margaritas I
we're still really good friends it went
fine we make you probably haven't even
seen this episode Haley I was like why
are people selling poison
to make people black out that's not what
alcohol should be for this is 35.
but like
I'm saying this was a prefer bottle this
big it was a one person's eyes it was
like a can that's insane it was one
serving that's insane and we're sipping
this you know what I mean and like I'm
just learning that alcohol can be to
make to connect deeper not go numb and
forget
yeah
a hundred percent you're looking at me
like this is this girl's sad this is no
we need to hang out more most Americans
don't know like live like that we don't
know to how to enjoy life
yeah
yeah that's why I don't live here I come
here for two days at a time and I get
the fuck out
[Laughter]
but so tell me like because as someone
that is
I mean look I do a lot of shit but you
are a lot of shit but you are spinning
so many plates and I just go
what are what are the pieces of advice
you got that
that change your life and what are the
little things as someone that is now
starring in movies little things where
you know what
what are your rituals where you take
care of yourself and make it so you
don't break in half
that's a good question uh besides your
sister doing everything
yeah I mean I'm I'm very close to my
family I mean you saw that but but most
people's family aren't as cool as your
family like
he's close to his family but a lot of
times that makes someone
a nightmare you're like can you be less
close to your family because they're
like his your family is like you guys
are like best friends my mom was always
like my friends would come to my house
to hang out with my mom not hang out
with me she's we're literally at this
table I'm a comedian you're a famous
comedy actor you literally they cast
people off Tick Tock that were the funny
had the fun your mom is funnier than
anyone we're like put her in the movie
like she should do my part like she's
hilarious she actually has a small part
in in the movie oh that's right and she
did not want it was just we we needed
someone who was American my mom is from
Detroit uh for this little bit and and
Jonah went up to my mom was like Astrid
can you please she's like no no no no no
no no no
no no she had a couple of gin tonics
showed up on Savage
he's like okay Jonah what do you want me
to do
I was like God like hold on let me just
buy this nft okay I mean she was running
a whole like digital economy during
dinner she's like buying out of tea
she's buying bored ape she's like buying
ethereum she's like so my digital wallet
meanwhile I'm like I can't get on Wi-Fi
in Mexico can someone help me she's like
all right I just I'm On One Crazy on
that one we were shooting I think she
was bored and she was just like what you
know she's very smart she was in banking
yeah and you know she was like what can
I do okay great I'm gonna you know hop
on this and she taught me it's like
I think we're so trained to go like as
you move on in life you're a mom like
now
you don't get to have your own life
anymore I was like oh my she's like
Curious she taught me stuff or she's
like check out this uh Ted Talk check
out this this and I was like oh I was
kind of excited at 40 to stop learning
and to have the excuse like la la la I
don't know she's just like no I'm not
gonna my life's just beginning you know
and I think that's like the coolest
thing she inspired me so much she's
she's she's I mean she's the life of the
party always how did you you and Monica
I'm obsessed with the fact that in
romantic comedies I'm just gonna say it
in the past
I just did a really brutal uh graphic
sex scene that's coming out on the fox
show next week I have this theory that
until very recently no sex scene has
been acting like everyone kind of
secretly drinks we're just like let's
just kind of
go for it because it'll look better you
know what I mean we I'm not speaking for
you but like in TV before like I have a
boyfriend you have a girlfriend
we have 20 minutes to shoot this because
the production's a mess and not there's
no intimacy there's no one there you
know it's an open set they say it's a
closed set it's not and you're just like
let's just fucking make out let's just
drink three things of fucking vodka just
fuck up and kind of just do it because
like honestly if you're doing a sex
scene or kissing you're not gonna be
like well this is how the character
would you just do what you would you
know
like don't try to like when you see a
character doing a sex scene you're like
well that's how you fuck I mean it's
just it it's like you're not like well
the character might might like put his
hand on the wall it's like
you're doing you know what I mean let's
just be real that's why I've never been
on top in a scene and so
so like also like Kiss like sometimes in
a lot of romantic comedies actors and
I'm not faulting you guys that that came
before us because we had to look to
people before us and then I'm on all
these sets with and I'm like you guys
are really in flirting like you're re
you know and like to have
the chemistry that you and Monica have
and the
it felt to me like what like how I felt
when I watched Princess Bride
when I was when I was 12. I'm in this
movie I know it's fake you guys I was
there
it's fake but you know I mean I was like
I was swept away and I think I'm
probably one of the more cynical people
at this point and I was like
I was like rooting for YouTube like I
was like I was with um two other people
and they're watching it and then I got
this phone call and they're like shut up
like we have to see what's gonna happen
I mean even though we're like we know on
some level they're probably gonna end up
together but everyone was like
what's good at like everyone was so
invested and I was like I cannot
remember the last time
I didn't watch your romantic comedy go
okay
all right you know what I mean it was so
it made me feel like a 12 year old girl
watching Pretty Woman which yes is about
a prostitute maybe we should have
watched that at 12 but sex worker we
don't say that anymore
Street horror whatever
um and let me was there ever a time
where you were on set and you were like
I get insecure about like I don't want
to be too cool for I'm too cool for
school I don't want to be vulnerable I
you know sometimes we'll do the take
that's kind of a little less
open because it's embarrassing to be
vulnerable was there ever a moment in
there where you and Jonah the director
were like let's just
be the white knight in this moment
because I think a lot of male actors
like yeah well
I'm not gonna be the White Knight we
want the white we want the most
incredible love story that can be told
that's not toxic and you guys did that
how
I mean
honestly
Monica is
amazing
and working with her was
a blast and you met her over Zoom
because it was the pandemic yeah and I
had coveted so uh he literally didn't
have taste and he still had good taste
I was stuck in Madrid Jonah wanted to do
chem reads and I and and so did I
because everyone should I mean that's
what makes her breaks a rom-com it's
really all about the chemistry that that
the two romantic leads have and that
doesn't mean they have to be in love in
real life you can both be married it's
just like no no no do we
sometimes I've been in situations where
I'm in a scene with someone that's I'm
supposed to be and I can't even like
hear what they're saying they'll be like
how's your dad I'm like huh like we just
aren't the same ilk it's hard to explain
but we I don't feel like I can go was
that good I'm like chemistry's not just
about on screen it's about you're
spending two months with someone
all day every day
I remember perfectly you know so I was I
was gonna be in La doing the chem reads
but I was in Madrid I got covered I was
stuck in the dirt it was like four in
the morning I was doing these chem reads
and Monica was the first actress
and I was just so out of it I couldn't
figure out the zoom and how to work and
she was like no no like just try this
and do that and from that second from
that instant I was just like
this is it that's just her yeah like
when you talk about chemistry yeah you
know like what like what you were just
talking about you know and I just saw
Jonah's look and you know he was just
texting me he's like yes yes let's get
her lock her down and we started doing
the scenes and you know Monica just you
know
just brought it and it's a shame she's
not gorgeous enough to be a leading lady
I mean it's a shame you know I mean it's
a shame
I saw Monica in person for the first
time and she looks like a Westworld
robot you're like how are you can I tell
you the secret to her beauty
it's inside too
her dad is a neurosurgeon
she's her guy is a naval she's not like
a Hollywood
the character I play I just went every
piece of bad behavior I've seen I'm
gonna put into this character so that
people go oh
I shouldn't act like that in that surely
Temple Joe it gets me every single it's
true this business was built on the back
of a four-year-old toddler named Shirley
Temple I will say it all day long every
day so blood on your hands Justice for
Shirley Temple and I'm gonna say this
once no I'm not I'm gonna say it all at
once in the next hour
Shirley Temple was four when she was the
star of all these movies right four or
five that means she was cast at two
because it takes two years to make a
movie
at we know how movies get made so and
then if she was cast that means a
hundred other toddlers came in
to audition and people went not pretty
enough not good so for every one actress
child actress you see on scene there
were 200 that were rejected
as babies
dimples not deep enough get rid of her
what and then for every scene you see
her in sitting on men's laps with no Mom
in sight no babies nothing
that means that scene was choreographed
for two days they had to go surely do it
again and just and then when they said
cut she was sitting on the lap in real
life
waiting for the you know what I mean
it's like it wasn't just what you saw
there was costume designers who were
like we got to make the we have to cover
the diaper like they went they spent
five days deciding the length of the
skirt
anyway thank you for letting me put in
the movie Okay so yes I love the fact
that we're calling you're calling out
Hollywood while also
celebrating the best
the things that Hollywood does best you
just feel how the vibe like and also to
have a scene play out for five six
minutes movies now they're like they're
just making scenes to get them over with
it's like story story
letting your scene breathe when Monica's
character is processing with them about
what to do the leaving in because
usually you're in post and people cut it
cut it we need this scene shorter why
no one goes to see a movie to be like
let's get out of here I'd rather this be
short than good
the audience is like I'm on a date I
would love a movie that's this that
can you make this longer and good
instead of why are you trying to save my
time I I'm coming to a movie you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it didn't feel
like
cut too tight does that this is you I
feel like you're looking at me like yeah
Whitney we know no no no no no I think
most viewers don't haven't seen a movie
like this in like 15 years
in a romantic comedy in America at least
it's just hearing all this makes my day
really I mean especially coming from you
you know it's not the even this I've
said this before before I had this
tequila he doesn't make a tequila that
makes you compliment him by the way
that's the secret he's like we need a
tequila that makes I was doing that
before this
he didn't roofie me
so it's like I just hope you're ready
like
do you want to be more I I
are you okay with being as famous as you
are and how you're gonna get
like
I I honestly don't even think of that
smart yeah like I just
I love what I do
I feel so lucky to be able to
do what I love and what I'm passionate
and you're really good about not
surrounding yourself with anyone that
like uses you or has ulterior motives
that's hard to do though I try to
surround myself with with good people
like I said I'm really close to my
family that that keeps me grounded in a
big way my sister and they'll tell you
if someone comes around they're like I
don't know about this person you know
good yeah yeah and yeah my sister was
working at JP Morgan you know like she
went to Duke she's a she's so smart and
I was like Natalia please you know come
come join the company you know she's
she's been around what I do for a very
long I've been doing this for 20 years
started when I was 12. so she's been
around it a lot uh but you know and you
know having her having
Josh Glick who's my manager and best
friend who's also one of the producers
in the movie Dave bernin who was my
roommate producer you were just like
they're my friends I I've never had a
roommate that can produce anything but
puke and trash
sorry
you had a roommate with their shit
together that literally never happens
I'm not sure if he has a shit together
he's your shit together
you know but if you ever had a moment
where you were just like not ungrateful
but just like Ugh
I kind of just wish I wasn't famous just
today
yes but then I moved to the states I had
to start again from
and then I was like oh shit America was
giving shit about people Kylie Minogue
remember Kylie Minogue
Robbie Williams no one gave a shit dude
no one cared couldn't I mean they use
biggest star everywhere in the world but
in the US that's why he lived here but
you know then I moved here and I had to
start again from ground zero and I was
like damn you know you're pre-reading
for uh like a a co-star you're like um
guys I yeah and then you start to
appreciate that you know you're like
just be thankful yeah and then
um what's next I'm gonna what's next is
I'm Gonna Let You Go eventually
um from being captive in my house but
are you able to still like balance your
music career also like do you have to
pick for people that are like I I want
to see him on tour well that like what's
I put music on hold in like 2015 which
was like the last time that I released
something because you just can't do both
at the same time it's impossible will
you ever do a musical movie
I I would do another the first movie I
ever did was Rock of Ages with uh with
with Tom Cruise and he's another one I
mean
he was so great when you know that it
was my first movie and I was I was so
nervous I was shitting my pants yeah Tom
Cruise Alec Baldwin Catherine Zeta Jones
Paul diamanti just got a bob you know
I'd be shitting my pants too
no it's okay you're not a you're not a
woman so it's fine you're safe
sorry you're not the only female VP we
have
she got her sorry no we have rib around
just you know I had a project with
alcohol when he played my dad in a
sitcom and it didn't work out so dodge a
bullet
um
I'm sorry I'll got that if you want
sorry
it's the tequila the tequila made me sad
I was anyway
no but I mean you know I was I was I was
so nervous going in and I remember
uh
were at the table read
and you know I I I I'd done a couple of
TV shows here and done table reads and
you know they're like you know just the
cast of course
and they come up and they're like Diego
do you want to play guitar for the table
I'm like yeah of course but you just
learn how to play guitar yeah well then
I'll practice of course yeah
show up and there's 150 people all the
heads of the studio there's a huge table
there's microphones there's speakers
and I'm going oh shit by the way that's
not normal to have my when you go into a
table read that's just not on camera
this is when we just practice the script
it's we do a dry rehearsal to show the
writers when they put a microphone on
you you're like wait a minute
this is not how we did it at that
apartment for my last product you know
what I mean it's like yeah it's so
intense for no reason and rows of Studio
execs there and I I'll go over my left
shoulder Tom Cruise is walking out in
character after being in the makeup
chair for four hours
and then I look to my right and Alec is
so nervous he can't even highlight his
own lines and I'm like oh great this is
going to be one of those table reads
when you know they fire the actor
because hey fucked up happens all the
time which happens all the time and I'm
like well I can't back down I said I was
going to play guitar whatever
and I had never played guitar and sung
uh in front of I I literally just
learned how to play Don't Stop Believing
and it was like two weeks into guitar
lessons amazing so the prop Master comes
in he's like you know giving me the
guitar he's like yeah good luck and I'm
like okay shit and I I start playing
Don't Stop Believing the table read I
mean the room is not cold it's freezing
not a single and then all of a sudden
Tom was sitting two chairs to my right
he stands up
the room goes silence like someone
pressed pause and he just comes up to me
what are you doing tonight I was like uh
watching Game of Thrones he's like no
let's learn how to play guitar together
you know let's do guitar lessons you
know we're both learn learning from the
same dude from EJ I'm like yeah of
course yeah tonight oh of course oh yeah
great great
I'm thinking you know he's just being
nice right that night I'm watching Game
of Thrones 8 P.M un or private or block
number
hi Diego it's Tom come on up
well where just you know we're all
staying in the same apartment building
in South Beach beautiful building the
Continuum I'm in this beautiful
apartment he's in the penthouse of
course yeah I'm like okay he's like just
gone up he's like I'm gonna send the jet
to get you to the second floor what
and and I I go up with my with my with
my guitar EJ's there who's the who's the
guitar coach uh and uh he gives me a
notepad and a pen and he goes listen man
I jump off of buildings I do my own
stunts they asked me if I wanted to play
guitar I said no uh and then I saw you
you know and you just play guitar I mean
it it kind of reminded me like he's like
in your hairline made me want to jump
off a building
he's like listen
uh
here's everything I wish I knew when I
was 20 years old
ah just
you know and he it was like he would we
spoke about Paul Newman he told me about
working with Dustin Hoffman and Rain Man
also Paul Newman real quick I you remind
me of Paul Newman because you know that
he did those salad dressings yeah
Newman's Own and he donates all the
proceeds
he didn't he that was like he was a good
person off camera I love that shit yeah
and yeah and hot
and a great actor
and hot
was he good I don't know he's I just I I
just I was a kid I would look at the
salad dressing and be like that makes my
my lower regions feel weird
blue cheese plus his face like what do
you need that was like my porn like just
like eating a blue cheese and like I
would just drink and like the
vinaigrette
sorry
Paul Newman yeah well so Paul Paul
Newman Dustin Hoffman and he's like
this is everything I wish I knew when I
was oh no he starts asking me about just
literally everything about me uh where'd
your parents parents meet how long have
they been together so all the stuff I
should have been doing on this podcast
he did
I mean he's like asking me like like
where my mom was born how old my
siblings were uh just everything and by
the way he really wants to know the
answer like sometimes people ask shit
like that and they're just being
bullshit three weeks later my brother
came to set he was waiting for me
outside the bathroom
and Tom walks up he's like are you are
you going he's like no no I'm just
waiting for my older brother he goes oh
you're Santiago
my brother just goes just why does it uh
yeah it's like Diego told me you love
basketball right you love the Lakers you
know my son's coming and coming in this
weekend let's let's play ball this
weekend
but that's like to me
I'm gonna say it you cannot be the
biggest star in the world
and beguile millions of people and not
be like that off camera
I don't think you can fake that for that
long he knew everyone's not only
everyone's name on on the crew but their
wives their kids I mean everyone in that
movie would have taken a bullet for him
yeah like including me yeah I was I was
like this like and Alec Baldwin was
gonna make sure they did
sorry I know you I just you're going my
publicist is gonna make sure you cut
that out let me make sure there's a
clean cut there you're holding because
you
sorry what I mean Alec whatever you know
me we're homies can I tell you something
this is the biggest endorsement I can
have for a tequila
Diego has had three sips
and I'm not even stressing him out
[Laughter]
you know how incredible that is I'm like
yeah and he's like yeah totally he's
just surfing this like it's a wave
most people
when they do this podcast they feel like
a trapped animal in a cage fighting for
their life oh I I don't feel that at all
they're just like I'm I'm having a blast
talking to you and I love
this cologne I'm like I'm like
constantly just so glad you like it it
was by the way buying a man cologne who
you're not in a relationship with is
weird there were a couple times where
like my clone too intimate weird gift no
no
it's so damn if your girlfriend hates it
it goes in the trash okay okay because I
don't want her to be like I'm smell you
know it's tobacco smell why do I love so
good it's really good
um so real quick before we go when is
this going to be available in America
because this is going to change
everything the goal is to make this the
number one silver to kill in Mexico and
then bring it to the states and tell
that story and be like listen this is
the number one silver tequila in Mexico
yep it's not 200 bucks nope not 100
bucks 35 32 dollars
insane can I pitch taglines real quick
and then you go absolutely who says I
want to go by the way I I'm just like
feel like I'm holding you captain and
then he's he's starting to disassociate
how do I pronounce it without being
racist
perfect
the front there tequila that won't make
you text your ex
the Friend Day
all the upsides of tequila without
masturbating in public
the Fred
murder
absolutely zero hookers
uh I mean I could do this all day
do you want to be the face
you will not puke in a graveyard
the vet day you will not puke on
anyone's Grave by accident
I once got wasted and got lost in a
graveyard the Friend Day
you will not spend more than thirty five
dollars on tequila
yeah you know what I mean like it's like
it's just it's tequila without all the
bad decisions and migraines
yes you know that the stereotype for
tequila is that it makes you make bad
decisions
that's not this
yeah you know what I mean just you wait
for Mexico City there's it is it is
going to be it's gonna be the most fun
shit ever so much fun and you have to go
to San Miguel de Allende but when am I
gonna do that is that that's a separate
trip though yeah so
you can fly to Mexico City it's a
three-hour Drive I my aunt and uncle
live there like you can stay with them
you by the way don't offer shit like
that because I'll be like hey I'm here
what's the address I'm serious okay I'm
serious I'm like what about Bob have you
seen that movie no oh my God it's the
it's Bill Murray Richard Dreyfus it's
I've seen a lot of movies that are old
because I had an older brother it's What
About Bob
Bill Murray
it's his therapist he gets so
emotionally attached to his therapist
that he has to be the therapist and the
therapist says I'm taking a week off to
go on vacation with my wife
in his family and Bill Murray shows up
because he's like hey I need to talk and
he go he won't leave like it's called
what About Bob like he'll just
I will show up
and be like I'm here and you'll be like
that was kind of a a I just said that
and now you're at my aunt's house and
I'm shooting like you know what I mean
I'll take you up on it
love it like and you have to come this
2023 is the year that I actually go on a
vacation for real without working
through the whole vacation
you will fall in love with somebody
especially after seeing your house and
like the vibe that you like and
everything
it is it's it's a magical Town it just
is here's the thing every time I drive
over the Mexico border I get stopped
because of what's in my purse this is
the year they let me in
and I stay and you stay
okay there's a couple stem cell
treatments they only offer in Mexico so
I will be there very soon I hear the
cocaine's way better that's why I'm
gonna do cocaine for the first time
so I like joking I I can't do I don't
ever want to do a cane I feel like I
would start a I can't start any new
businesses
I mean people always say like when you
have to try cocaine I'm like no I don't
want to make any new friends and I don't
want to start new businesses I already
have enough I think that's what happens
we need to find you a
good Mexican dude yes please okay I want
like a cowboy like a Rancher uh like a
like a horse guy yeah cowboy boots the
Yellowstone of Mexico correct bye
like a country fucking guy that can
build houses and like
make me squirt
sorry I've never I feel like everyone's
squirting I'm like I don't
I
I don't I think you guys are just peeing
like I don't think
I'm not out here squirting maybe I'm
just dehydrated I don't know but I feel
like there's a lot of things sexually
that are happening that I'm not
getting and I think I need to stop
dating Hollywood people that yeah you
know I love being an actor but I'm not
acting in the bedroom anymore those days
are over
foreign
but yes I don't dude I can't with these
white guys it's a nightmare
they're sorry they need so much
sunscreen like can I tell you vacate
I just want a vacation with a guy that I
don't have to put sunscreen on their
back
the white guys are a nightmare even when
I vacation to Mexico if you bring a
white guy they just ruin everything I
went to Tulum for two weeks the guy's
sunburned after day one I went to Puerto
Vallarta with a guy he's like scared of
snakes I'm like I just need a guy that's
Mexican
yeah because you can enjoy Mexico with a
white American guy they don't get it no
no they're rude to the stuff you're like
what are you doing well just I'm telling
you
we're gonna do Mexico City I swear to
God and then we're gonna do San Miguel
and this podcast like when you look I'm
not ever gonna ask the same questions
other people ask you
when I do an interview and people go
what's like being a female comedian I'm
like I've answered that somewhere 15 ask
me a question no one's asked people
already have seen all your other
interviews they're coming here to see a
side of you right so it's my job to make
sure I'm asking things no one's asked
you yeah I love that you know so you're
not bored I'm not bored and they're not
bored and so
I try so hard in my life now to be
sagacious with my time and to make sure
I don't let anyone into my life
romantically professionally platonically
that is
dangerous even though it's not their
fault right someone that's
you know has ulterior motives someone
who's not healed yet someone that had
you know saw something in their
childhood they're repeating what they
saw I believe everyone is just doing
what they were programmed to do unless
they've actively worked to deprogram so
sometimes people hurt people by accident
her people hurt people right what is
something you've learned over time that
is a red flag in a new person whether
you're hiring dating anything and it's
not their fault we're not judging but
like for example I always say to guys if
a girl asks you to take a picture of
them on a first date for their social
media that's a red flag
you know I know guys are like I want a
date with this girl
and she was like can you take a picture
of me I know what someone who's dating
you and doesn't put you on their social
media you're famous so it's different
but like things like that
huge red flag for me is if I'm on a date
and the girl that I'm on a date with
is
you know treats the waiter or whoever
poorly
I'm not clapping loud so the sound
doesn't suck number one red flag it's
one day that's gonna be you
that they taught that they talked if if
if if they talked to the waiter like
that one day they're gonna talk to you
like that I love that you say this
because behind you not bragging Two
Broke Girls the pilot episode of this
the wages yeah the pilot was her being a
waitress and the the big the opening
cold open was uh Cat Daddy's character
coming out and the the disrespectful
people going waitress waitress that was
the open
and she went she goes yes can I help you
can I help you and she was rude back
going what would you like to have yeah
to eat tonight
you know and then she goes like
something something and we got in
trouble but they aired it and we fought
for it and she went because when you do
this it makes my vagina dry up
whatever and so it's like that the fact
that it's just disrespect treating
people that are service people as if
they're less than you yeah like just
because someone's waiting on you just
because someone works at a boutique does
not mean they're beneath you
or rude to their employees just because
someone works for you does not mean you
get you're not I had this conversation
today with everyone I went just because
you're not paid
to feel bad
at this job if you're confused or feel
bad it's my job to make sure that you
have the information you need to not be
confused it's my fault if you're
confused you know and I think a lot of
employers kind of get off on watching
their employees go that's not what
you're you're not employing someone
so they get cancer at your job you know
yeah remember you walked in and I said
new policy the end of every day
15-minute dance party
we're gonna dance to the Beyonce song
energy energy
this in five years will
get me canceled because employees are
gonna go I had to dance with Whitney for
15 minutes at her house and she thought
it was like build morale but it was kind
of just creepy
like that could go sideways but my
heart's into my place
hey what's up with Whitney uh uh she
can't make the sequel to at midnight
because she's in a lawsuit oh because
her employee's suing her I said to Grace
and and Katie I was like end of every
day why don't we do a 15-minute dance
party just to like Shake It Off and like
remind ourselves that we're all dying
and we can't take ourselves too
seriously they were like uh they just
literally laughed Grace was like um good
I'm just dancing with my employees like
let's go yeah they're like HR help gross
I'm like take your clothes let's go
let's get in the hot tub together this
is how it starts this is this is Ellen
20 years ago was like guys dance party
it really was that's that's all that
comes see now that I'm drinking this
your tequila I'm thinking more clearly
that never happens I had two sips of
this and I was like dance party bad idea
I make better decisions drinking this
that never happens uh at midnight comes
out para so you guys the 10th it will be
streaming on Paramount plus yes
worldwide and the kind of laughter
you're getting in this movie is medicine
period so just take your medicine
take your medicine
I'm gonna really I'm learning Spanish
you guys I I'm making this promise on
this podcast today done I'm not gonna be
perfect no but I'm gonna get it right
love it
what Haley
we on this podcast we say the same thing
at the end of every podcast and guess
what our our glasses can you see this
what do we say on three Haley one two
three don't don't ride elephants
I love you guys bye
[Music]